the ninth installment of the fast and
the furious franchise is
racing toward the finish line and onto
the big screen the latest movie in the
high octane series was released in hong
kong
south korea and russia in may 2021 and
soon the rest of the world will be able
to join in on the gasoline
scented action and thrills of f9 the
film broke
records at the box office debuting at
163 million dollars in its international
opening and with earnings for the
franchise
now over 6 billion dollars worldwide
with those numbers
it doesn't look like the movie will be
stepping on the brakes anytime soon
the fast and furious movies have been on
track for 20 years now and the newest
film promises more wild stunts and
heart-pounding chases than ever before
f9 sees the return of director justin
lin who previously helmed the fast and
furious films three through six
here's everything we know about the film
so far the f9 movie has been in limbo
for nearly two
years with various delays causing the
film to be pushed back several
times the initial plan would have seen
f9 in theaters back in the summer of
2019
but that release date was put on hold to
make room for the release of the buddy
comedy spin-off hobbs and shaw
universal the film's distributor then
made plans for a may 2020 release
but had to push things back once again
because of the pandemic
at last the wait for american audiences
will soon be over
as f9 finally releases stateside on june
25th
2021 now that the us has seen a surge of
vaccinations to fight off the
coronavirus
film studios are optimistic that more
audiences will be flocking to theaters
this summer
with many public places reopening and
lifting many of their restrictions
universal is hoping that f9 will be as
big of a box office
smash in the states as it has been
overseas fast and furious fans are no
doubt
eager to see the return of their
favorite characters in the long awaited
sequel
and they will not be disappointed
franchise veteran vin diesel leads the
cast of
f9 reprising his role as protagonist
dominic tiretto
dominic has come a long way from the
first film in the series from leading
his own gang of criminals
to becoming a fugitive on the run to
graduating to a kind of
high profile gray market mercenary
tasked
with taking down some of the most
dangerous crime lords
around the world you got the best crew
in the world
standing right in front of you give them
a reason to stay
michelle rodriguez returns as letty
ortiz the toughest
nails mechanic and the love of dominic's
life letty and dom have been through a
lot together over the years from letty's
supposed death to her amnesia
and the ultimate return of her memories
if their history is
anything to go by it's unlikely that the
couple will have much time to themselves
in the newest film
also returning for f9 are tyrese gibson
as roman pearce
chris ludacris bridges as tesh parker
jordana brewster as mia toretto
and lucas black as tokyo drifts sean
boswell a notable addition to the cast
of course
is john cena who will play jacob toretto
dom's long-lost brother who has become a
master thief and assassin
charlize theron will return as cyber
terrorist cipher teaming up
as the co-antagonist alongside cena's
jacob the official summary promises
multiple settings in f9 and has the crew
trotting around the globe in the newest
film
london tokyo and edinburgh are just a
few of the locations mentioned
along with central america and the
scenic capital of lysi georgia
the summary also reads along the way old
friends will be resurrected
old foes will return history will be
re-written
and the true meaning of family will be
tested like
never before also of note the furious
crew will
finally be heading into outer space
because of course they will
long time fast and furious fans know how
much family means to don
i don't have friends i got family
although we don't know much about jacob
at this point there is certain to be
plenty of conflict as dom goes up
against his long-lost brother
and seeing him team up with one of dom's
most dangerous foes from the past
is sure to pile on the drama and of
course most importantly
han is back nice clubhouse
we can't wait to see how dom and his
crew take on this newest set of
challenges when f9
finally arrives in the u.s check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you